Few things in childhood are more traumatising
than waking up one morning to find your beloved
pet fish, Michael Scofield, floating upside
down in his tank (true story); his tiny fishy
light cruelly extinguished before his time.
But why do they float upside down when they
decide it’s time to take a ride on the porcelain
express?
The answer to this question has a lot to do
with how they maintain proper buoyancy when
they’re alive.
As you may or may not know, most fish are
in possession of an organ commonly known as
a “swim bladder”.
This organ can be filled or emptied of air
by a fish at will via its gills, allowing
them to either float higher, sink lower or
stay suspended at about the same depth, not
unlike a Buoyancy Compensator (BC) used by
scuba-divers.
Although swim bladders are critical to a fish’s
ability to float, sink or hover without expending
much energy, they have the unfortunate side
effect of making them rather unstable.
To explain, research has shown that the relative
position of a fish’s “centre of buoyancy”
is, amongst fish with swim bladders, almost
universal located below their centre of mass
near their stomach, making them quite prone
to hydrostatic rolling which is just a fancy
way of saying it makes them more likely to
go belly up.
This is why fish can often be seen flapping
their fins, even when they’re not moving
and in perfectly still water.
This is also why when fish become ill or injured,
they will sometimes begin swimming on their
side or even upside down; they simply lose
the ability to maintain hydrostatic equilibrium
and the more buoyant part of their body will
try to float to the surface.
When fish ultimately die, of course, they
lose all ability to stop themselves rolling
over and the buoyancy of the swim bladder
takes over.
It should also be noted that fish don’t
necessarily always float when they die.
For example, if a fish dies with little to
no air in its swim bladder, the act of dying
doesn’t magically make this bladder expand
to increase buoyancy.
In these cases, the fish will often sink,
at which point decomposition will begin.
That said, the decomposition process can sometimes
result in enough gas being produced and trapped
inside the fish to cause it to float to the
surface.
So in short, fish float upside when they die
because many of them are top heavy and posses
and organ in their lower region that is filled
with air.
While it’s entirely within the realm of
possibility for a goldfish to live for 3 decades,
this is, rather sadly, almost never the case.
Although, given that goldfish are extremely
intelligent fish, contrary to popular belief,
and people often just put them in a little
glass bowl with no real way for them to entertain
themselves or be mentally stimulated, perhaps
not living for three decades in such an environment
is preferable.
Swim bladders are by no means a universal
trait all fish share.
For instance, neither sharks nor rays possess
the organ, the latter due to their mostly
bottom dwelling nature.
Sharks do have a large liver that is filled
with a lighter-than-water oil, making them
naturally somewhat more buoyant than they’d
otherwise be.
Not having a swim bladder is also an advantage
for sharks in that swim bladders can rupture
if the fish ascends too quickly, which is
probably another reason sharks, which rely
on moving quickly to hunt and survive, didn’t
evolve to have
them or evolved away the trait.